you have dogs that bark at you
relentlessly when you get home
apparently my neighbor does if you have
to ask the question does this leak
memory let's just assume the answers yes
do you ever use pointers then your
program probably leaks memory if you
have to ask the question does this leak
yeah it does it does so I'm really all
I'm going to explain is why it leaks
memory when you use pointers and some
some really easy ways to prevent it okay
so first of all I'm gonna show you a
memory leak condition oh look at that
it's already on my screen you see this
just a pointer to a double called fiver
and creating a new double it's pretty
standard pointer stuff now what happens
when you exit the program or a function
that this isn't you know okay I know
I'll tell you the pointer goes out of
scope but the data does not it's just
still sitting there
I put the pointer to it is gone that's
the memory leak so if I just ran this I
don't know if C++ might be smart enough
to clean them up at the end of the
program I would assume not though but
this just on its own leaks memory so how
do you fix it well before you exit when
you're all done using your pointer to
your thing you just do this
that's it no longer leaks memory would
you like to know more press 1 for yes
press f to pay respects to memory you
lost alright so if you have pointers all
over in your code and use them all the
time in functions and you and you don't
delete them when you're done with them
and they're just going out of scope and
you think that frees the memory well it
doesn't it frees the pointer but it
doesn't do anything with the memory so
memory leak now what's what's hilarious
to me is that most people code for a
really long long long time before
figuring this out or at least I did
don't don't judge me okay don't it's not
what this is about
this isn't about judging each other
smash like to not judge others okay
let's let's continue a little further
well by 2014 people finally decided this
is dumb because you know when your your
program gets complicated and you have to
clean up pointers all over the place and
maybe you have things that create them
in a function and you know it just
becomes chaos when a large program and
this could be anything this could just
be an integer this could be some class
that you made off to the side anything
you make a pointer to you have to delete
it and what if there are more pointers
within the data well you have to
properly go through that data and clean
up all the pointers within there it's
just chaos it so finally not in C++
standard 11 but in C++ standard 14
people decided that this is this is
terrible
and it kinda is so there's this thing
that you can get if you use in C++ 14 in
the memory header and this thing is
called let's see if anyone can guess it
before it goes say it chat before I type
it you got two seconds one okay it's
called unique pointer now all unique
pointer is is a pointer that frees its
data at that deletes its data when it
goes out of scope so it's just like that
normal pointer before except we didn't
have to delete it and manage all that
crap we can just assume that it cleans
up itself so to use an unique pointer
it's in the standard library and you
declare what type of one maybe we want
to double here this can be a class
whatever any kind of data object and you
give it a name like I don't know since
there's like a million barking dogs in
the background I'm gonna call this
barking dog
all right so there you go there's a
unique pointer and to fill it with data
I could do an equals right here and make
unique I think you do the type again
here if I remember correctly and then in
parentheses you do whatever you want to
fill it with I don't know we'll put a
5/5 dot two or three in here there we go
now we have a pointer to a double with
the value of five point three in it
whereas before hardly key one would have
been like this new of the same type
except when we would have had to delete
this one to clean it up whether this one
with a unique pointer one you don't have
to clean it up all you have to do is let
it go out of scope all done all right so
so you'll you'll find you might have
some questions about this of course you
can go look it up there are a gazillion
answers online just google unique
pointer skip over geeks for geeks
website that's always at the top because
that's gonna be a bunch of nonsense
and look for the actual
Ian dot cpp site you know that has the
actual c++ standard stuff and lookup
unique pointer on there
and you will find details about it like
if i want to get just the raw pointer
out of this all i do is this dot get and
that's the pointer that's just like so
if you need if you have a function that
wants a pointer you can you can tighten
this in to do it this this is how you
stop leaking memory with your your
pointers you just use unique pointer and
stop worrying about it yes it took it
took the standard i don't know
when was did c c++ come out I know it
took like 20 years for him to decide
that this was a good idea talk about
things moving slow this is why you
should do things right away because if
you don't do it nobody else will that
program you've been wanting to right
start right now soon as the video ends
start using unique pointers in it there
you go if you don't do it someone else
will write it steal your idea and you'll
be like oh god that idea couldn't make
millions you got the idea do it boom
there's your motivation alright so I
guess I guess will compile this just
just stop judging me okay it's it's
seriously because I don't have a dash
right here
that's what's happening oh god I'm still
having a problem let's dig in let's
solve some more compiler issues
truncated to fit on defense yeah I don't
actually know what this is you ever get
something weird like this one thing you
can do is you can take the non nonsense
part of it if you see any like hashes
leave those out because Google is not
gonna understand you're for various
hashes and and just grab this and you'll
find answers this is probably not the
right one I might also be I think I
should I think what this actually is is
I should be using should I be using G
plus plus yes that was it
stop judging me oh I see you see you
through my camp all right so now this
works okay so it's GCC is hmm it's uh I
think just four C files g plus plus or c
plus plus this is a new compiler through
cygwin that was the problem so we ran it
nothing happened but if we see out this
thing something will happen
and we don't need to see Sandra vibe or
just use iostream for a moment see out
this sucker and we should get something
so we'll recompile and run it and we get
its address because this is the pointer
so if we do reference the pointer and
recompile we should get the value of
five point three as expected so that's
how you get two pointer out goes
otoscope doesn't leak everything's good
let's let's do one last thing well let's
say you try it with C++ 11 let see what
happens
error so if you get something that looks
like this not a member of standard you
need to do 14 instead okay well I hope
this helps somebody out there hope this
helps you guys not leak memory all the
time and write better more consistent
more stable programs I'm looking out for
you mostly looking out for me but I'm
also looking out for you so I'll see you
in the next episode peace out